okay now sounds ready yeah chips wrong
way yeah
now Great Britain are you ready to put
those scallops in the pan do not put the
scholars in the pan unless it is piping
hot and I mean piping hot right hand
over yeah hand over that's it let it
down and put it down to make sure it's
nice and hot I sent a shot
okay hot right let's go okay seen the
scallops right olive oil in the pan come
on Chris stay with me Oh God boy olive
oil olive oil Jason does it nicely
nice nice nice now when the surf
three-syllable oh yeah
season one side as they go in the pan
we'll see from the second side round
let's go Chris they're with me I'm with
you it may look like we're putting a lot
of seasoned on there but it's not we
lose 30% of it up and it hits the pan so
okay now this is the important part the
first column goes in at 12 o'clock 12
o'clock 1 o'clock 2 o'clock and so on
that's the noise you need to hear I'm
hearing it the two o'clock three o'clock
four o'clock
therefore they cook evenly why don't we
come round to actually one of my kind of
about 20 past four is that all right ah
place them in don't throw them in my
place them in now don't toss the pan
that's it place in the side good now do
it with the pan just roll it round the
side that's not to cut the back of the
scallop and these are my scallops so
therefore you know in terms of flavor is
extraordinary right season all the way
around right